in this capsule we will see the
different types of inference that we're going
want to do with Bezier networks
dynamic
we saw an example of visual networks
previously dynamic for the code of a
security guard who wants a ferrer 6
2 most not from observations
of his director who arrives or not with
an umbrella
in fact it is this structure of
absorb a dynamic we will not see it
badly often to better explore with
more details I would point out that
when we look at the dependencies that
are modeled also it's still
still seems reasonable despite
several assumptions of independence
we did, for example
actually seeing that the
did the director bring his
umbrella or not go basically
depends on if from there more for the day
even the fact that it rain before that
not change much about the fact that
I want to bring my umbrella
really 6th clowns have today
I see my umbrella
so the fact that only one arrow of
reality towards a goal missed it a lot of
meaning
and then now that the weather in a
day you're mostly dependent on the
day the method the day before
again from a point of view that at
halls it does not make sense
we might have wanted to add
other dependencies so have a
chain
marco come second-rate honored
departure of the ski as witness of
also to try to detect
maybe trends a little bit
even more complex there it is a rather
good approximation say that the weather
a day of departures actually only
of the weather the previous day
so now we will see bath with
a Bezier network that feels March to
what kind of questions what kind of
populist reasoning one could be
able to do to try
to finally infer the certain
some distributions in relation to
may hidden variables
extensis then first type of inference
which will be often done is what we
call filtering in English filtering
the goal is to calculate what we
call tops belief in English
believe stay the state belief is right
the
posterior distribution of the variable
hide the most recent
that is, magic not that we have
observed my observation variable for
the state one up to the moment t but
now I will be interested in what
is the posterior disruption of the
hidden variables x at the same time you are
so he has the time of the moment of the
last observation I made
we will also know what is it
now our belief about
the hidden state in the code of our
problem of the caretaker who wants to know
if the rain or not, it corresponds to
know what is the probability that he
there was rain today being
given that I observed my director has
led his umbrella or not from the first
day till today in a
application maybe a little bit more
interesting in the case of the robot that gets
moves into a building that wants to know
where are they in a
card when would that be to know that
know members to know what is it
his belief about on the position of the
rebound currently in the map being
given all the information that has
cumulated with his censors since since
that they are in the in the
building have been producing that
could want to do to different people
would be to make the prediction so in
this case we would like to know what is
the posterior distribution of a state
future of which farther than the time tai
chi and the last time where last
moments when we had observations
in this case we should know
what the distribution of material
aratory x more like or case is going to be
greatest arrival we have not be
positive and give back all the
observations I accumulated time 1
until you try it for example
I am interested in knowing how to make a
prediction of the probability that they
have rain in that jo
would essentially correspond to
do the calculation of this distribution
conditional there
the difference would be what is called the
smoothing of anglès movin one associates one
would like to know the distribution still
once a posteriori but on a state
hide it's so in the
observations of time one up to
the moment t
I could ask myself what is the
distribution of trouble to hide at a
kawka moment and actually enters i got 0.6
but I would like to put 1 between 1 and
so was not today but a stock
and instant structures strictly tools
that you are who can be so 1
until finally witness so by
example in the case of the guardian of
security could be wondering what is it
the probability that they had the
rain there is because if that would be
why is equal to witness a witness no
it corresponds and yesterday compared to
today what moment t and finally
maybe the different type what is
the most used in practice is that
the most plausible explanation
in this case we want a ferrer the
sequence of states hide so pu
only one is more interested
only one and hid one single moment
but really the sequence of all
ages the kachin states that will explain
the best possible observations
accumulates is so mathematically that
means that we search among all
the possible values ​​of the variables
hidden extracts up excited we get
retrieve their values ​​which has the
highest policy given the
observations I've accumulated from the moment
1 until the moment t so the rest of
the equation is simply
the observation that I can take my
conditional here I can rewrite it
like joining her on aix and on /
the marginal only on 1
so that's
definition of the conditional one
know well and now because
finish here does not depend on x and that
I want to make a maximization at
paris xe so not what this term there
constant with respect to x actually
find the maximum the value of the
sequence x that maximizes that term
it's the same thing that found me the
theme that maximizes only the
numerator so the join on x is this
so mathematically often it's this
problem there in africa we will try to
solve because he's a little bit
simpler and so a little more
concretely concrete in the code of
guardian who are trying to infer the
weather so in this case too it would be
to infer the weather over the entire sequence
so for every day every
last days since they
accumulate the observation of his
director who arrives or not with a
umbrella and in a more context
practice in machine translation if we
gave us a sentence in French of
data but that would be my observation
them
I will try to infer what is it
English translation that would be so
assigning an upstream value and
at the cash and 2 x 1 until then existed
found this production with the local
benefited the highest a posteriori
given my sentence in French
do automatic translation
finally be found one can the oven
put in the form of a ference
most plausible explanation and in
voice recognition we can do the
same thing, that is, we can
formulate the problem of finding the
sentence that were pronounced being
given a sound signal as being alone
the problem of finding the phrase that the
more likely given the signal
sound that was captured